[Musique]
oui bienvenue à paroles attaque même si
c'est mélissa mollen dupuis alors cette
semaine j'ai pas pu m'en a sauvé je vous
offre encore une chronique à saveur
électorale parce que c'est le sujet
assourdissant dans les nouvelles dans
les communautés je vous ai beaucoup
parlé de représentativité de partis
politiques de paysage politique mais
lorsque je voudrais qu'on met de l'avant
c'est aussi les sujets qui risquent de
se retrouver à l'ombre des élections et
pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est que j'ai
beaucoup de sujets qui touchent beaucoup
les communautés pendant la période
électorale mais qui vont pas
nécessairement
être aussi intéressantes pour la
communauté allochtone donc on a peur de
perdre du momemtum sur certains des
sujets qui avaient enfin eu une
visibilité une écoute une réaction
justement du public canadien et là je
pense beaucoup aux
découverte des corps des enfants sur les
sites des écoles résidentielles
mais c'est pas la seule chose c'est
toute cette discussion autour de ce qui
est dans le fond le racisme systémique
le système qui a été mis en place la
dissociation avec le sort des enfants
des personnes des communautés
autochtones tout ce qu'on était en train
de réussir à pouvoir amener de l'avant à
discuter commencent à tomber à l'ombre
justement des élections departed et je
dirais même ne serait-ce que les
caricatures vont prendre beaucoup plus
de place que des sujets qui sont très
sérieux et qui demande la tension depuis
des décennies et bien en perdant ce
momentum là on perd la chance de pouvoir
faire une réconciliation de guérison
auto de la communauté canadienne donc
c'est certain que ça inquiète beaucoup
de gens dans les communautés mais aussi
on parle des changements climatiques on
reçoit des rapports soient des promesses
on reçoit des fonds mais espère vraiment
une transformation qui va se faire d'un
parti à l'autre est ce que les élections
vont être vraiment une direction loin
justement d'une réalité qui va changer
le canada où est ce qu'on va pouvoir
continuer justement sur des et la sueur
des
les promesses qui ont été faites c'est
quelque chose qui est à réfléchir
lorsqu'on va rentrer dans toute la
discussion électorale et de voir si les
sujets qui touchent les communautés
autochtones qui touche les personnes
racisées vont être vraiment approché ou
réfléchie d'une façon plus profonde que
ce qui a été par le passé donc
si jamais il ya des sujets justement qui
tombe dans l'ombre des élections des
sujets qui ne sont pas discutées des
mêmes des enjeux par des enjeux
territoriaux on parle des pêcheurs de
homard dans l'atlantique qui eux pèchent
traditionnellement c'est des sujets qui
sont en train de perdre cette écoute là
pour au profit des élections donc
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer justement
des questions sur des sujets que vous
trouvez que ne sont pas assez discuté
pendant les élections des sujets qui
devraient apprendre beaucoup plus de
comment je faisais de friction juste
avant les discussions alors envoyez-nous
les questions partagées et les crown est
partagée d'ailleurs dans les
commentaires ce qui vous intéresse ce
que vous ne voulez entendre un peu moins
parler s'il vous plaît on va faire en
sorte que le suivi sujet autochtone
crème le degré alors je fais une belle
semaine